As you walk in,...
...you're faced primarily by these three very large, very strong paintings...
...and they are extraordinary.
Cy Twombly painted these with paintbrushes on sticks...
...dipped in acrylic red paint.
He then goes at these large canvases in a big performative sense...
..and that's what gives these paintings...
...a sense of great swirling vortex of energy...
...and you have this red on a slightly more fleshy, more ochre base.
There's no bright white canvas here.
It's quick drying.
So those big circles, those spirals is drying at a rate,...
...which allows it to also become a picture of the activity.
By the time you get to the top of the canvas,...
...it's almost like fireworks.
They're up there.
There's a kind of pyrotechnics.
It perhaps shows you a sort of unbridled, possibly destructive...
...and possibly quite lethal side to Bacchus.
The freedom to paint without limitations, without restrictions...
...really comes across in these works.